the computer impossible it is possible
all right let's try Knight f6 you have
not seen the last of me
okay let's close it up and try and
exploit the inferior and gameplay can we
get this closed no - take care Bishop
efore get here before there's pawn push
and takes Knight h4 stuff castle and
well let me throw a question of that guy
right away okay now what keep it simple
I want some locked pawns cleanup Queen
trade I really do that yes the Queen's
are off okay that's important yeah it's
a weakness b4 I want to get my knight
here maybe see that silly like it
doesn't really know in certain positions
I don't know what that's really doing
okay pawns on dark typically are gonna
be a good thing this Knight or can you
get here I want to keep this night
around a rain forest this pond hmm or
what about night here so I could get in
g5g for to get this exchange in finally
maybe that's okay also to play f6 to
reinforce this point it seems a little
little off but
if there's a tactic it will see it for
sure okay
Knight takes Knight rook takes I'm
defending my bishop what am I missing
all the way back stay coordinated
avoiding the bishop exchange okay so I
think I play back here keep an eye on
this pawn and this one and now my knight
wants to get to c5 so let's get there
really don't have any weaknesses jump
into this point get this pawn and now -
what next pawn push pawn takes Bishop
takes Bishop now they're my rock tell me
rook I want to trade light square bishop
somehow it's tough to work in how do I
get that hmm I want to open things up
because this rook is you can strain to
the pond so the more files that open up
the rooks won't be able to contest them
because it's constrained to be three
what is the plan I have a decent amount
of time let's see rook f8 the other one
here and then pawn push that might be an
idea actually maybe I want to prevent
this advance for right now because then
if this bishop has an eye on this point
a base point that's gonna be problematic
so let me do this really just I guess
exaggerating this nights on rooks on
darks pawns on dark squares since my
bishop is on light idea yeah now I can't
get this advanced in so easily huh I
might have a draw might do like a
back-and-forth thing okay so now my
knight I think no longer wants to be
here but rather here to put pressure on
this structure so that pushing here is
not going to be a good idea I think I
might be able to win this because
eventually I think the computer makes a
move even if it's even if there's a
drawback to it
so I think as long as I just go back and
forth I think this is the best that I
could really do I don't know how to
break down this structure any further if
there's ever this pawn push then this
becomes a target I'll shift my attention
over here on the a file and I might have
to play out like these 50 moves OOP I
didn't mean to do that I don't think it
really matters though we're gonna seem
is my not gonna be taken even if he is
then I could function on the dark
squares I'll enter a good versus bad
Bishop position should just probably go
back and forth like this so I have
there's no progress to really even be
made I believe that is exactly where my
knight belongs
yeah this is I got it I got a play out
like 50 moves and we're gonna see what
was the last time a pawn move was made
or capture upon mover capture what move
where we yeah do have time to check I'm
checking real quick how much time 127 I
just want to see what move I need to get
to g4 move 26 I need to get to move 76
I've moved 51 right now did you get 276
and then we're gonna see around that
point if the computers gonna make a pawn
move it's either gonna be a draw by
repetition we're gonna be seeing b4 in
which case I think I'll be able to
transition my attention on that apon I'm
gonna see soon enough 61 62 there's a
pawn move crap ah that pawn move I
wasn't expecting that one man there's
checks now I'm gonna giant not okay this
is not working however
maybe the computer stupid hang on
waiting on it might be stupid could I
win this ending good versus bad bishop
hang on it is a good versus bad bishop
huh just trade rooks oh my king needs to
sneak over oh man I'm in trouble I'm
getting made it or something yeah I'm in
trouble
crap I'm in trouble oh I'm getting mated
pawn push next uh mating that I wasn't
even thinking that they had that that
move this is B I can't stop at for me
that's brutal
I was thinking let me let me click get
this other way for a second let me go
back to that position I'll click those
that are you're watching I was so
fixated on just that Oh
back up I was so fixated on this really
being only the only realistic break why
wasn't I seeing this one hmm okay
actually I'm making a mental know that
this would really be the one to look
more into because after I take it maybe
taking towards the center would have
been better so these these rooks don't
spring to life but after this pawn push
when I take I'm the extra pawn that I
have is doubled and it's not as valuable
if this happens I take and my structure
remains really good anyhow that was the
quick mental note that I made after that
one